when Hajime Tabata took on the role of
director for Final Fantasy 15 in 2012
one of his first decisions was to
conduct an analysis of the current state
of the final fantasy brand in Japan the
results were not promising with Tabata
Sam saying in a new interview that the
franchise was considered a dying IP that
had already peaked I'm Lucy and welcome
to your resurrected gamespot news update
speaking to Game Informer to back to San
said the gravest situation of all was
that at the time we were starting Final
Fantasy 15 we didn't see an increase in
new fans of the franchise the brand
image of final fantasy wasn't really
clear the reality is not that the
situation is okay or in favor of us
rather it is more grave and serious than
we had initially thought the way we
understood Final Fantasy after our
analysis is that it was a dying IP that
had already peaked this claim the
general feeling you might wonder why
square enix would go forward with Final
Fantasy 15 Tabata sign says he believes
fans continue to have faith in the
developer to make something great
Sebastian went on to mention three core
qualities that he believes define the
Final Fantasy brand as described by Game
Informer these are a willingness to
challenge the status quo an exceptional
out of the ordinary experience and
cutting-edge technology to use the
hardware to the fullest according to to
back to San the last game to beat all
three was 1997's final fantasy 7 he also
contends that Final Fantasy 15 will rise
to the occasion any final fantasy
released after final fantasy 7 lakhs in
one or the other but what Final Fantasy
fans desire is a new entry that
encompasses all of these elements and
that is our objective with Final Fantasy
15 so are you excited for 15 or will it
be a disappointment after so long let me
know in the comments or come by me on
Twitter I'm at Lucy James games for more
on Final Fantasy keep the game spot
you